hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 21st 2016 what's going
on Hawaii how's it going oh I'm doing
good man
I hope you guys enjoy it's a holiday
weekend Dobie Dobie do and school Italy
pop you only have to work three days
unless your boss is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's always the other ones too or if
you're [ __ ] self-employed or if you're
not happy with your home life you'll
come up with a reason right to go back
into work just to [ __ ] avoid it yeah
you know what this year cuz uh you know
we've been getting the [ __ ] kitchen
done we don't have time to cook or
anything so we're actually going to
friend's house for Thanksgiving which is
which is great because they live in the
same city as us so we don't to go to the
[ __ ] Airport right no these [ __ ]
people waddling around you know those
people just oblivious of other you know
it's a great [ __ ] human being just
totally being all about yourself
oblivious moment is when [ __ ] people
you know there's a whole herd of people
just riding down an escalator and people
like the second they step off it they
don't keep walking and get the [ __ ] out
of the way they just just all [ __ ]
oblivious it's like you GU you were just
on the escalator there's 50 people in
front of you a hundred people behind you
sorry I got the game on
what a [ __ ] throw what the [ __ ] is
going on with the Packers this year man
don't [ __ ] get it anyways sorry about
the scream in there you know you got 50
people in front you got a hundred
[ __ ] people behind you you know and
people are getting off it kind of
meandering and you're on the escalator
thinking go go get out of the way before
we all fall down on each other right
it's very sort of a thinking human being
going like Oh assessing the problem well
when in in [ __ ] eight seconds when I
become that person I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] out of the way so whoever the [ __ ]
is twenty people behind me will not be
having in this panic moment because of
me
gonna become pirate part of the solution
not the [ __ ] problem right I don't
even know what I'm talking about at this
point I can't remember the point I was
trying to make but what I know what I'm
saying yeah but the kind of [ __ ]
people like you know was that how some
Thanksgiving that's right right so we're
gonna [ __ ] pee I have no idea what
point is you know what I mean I just
said a bunch of [ __ ] I hope it was funny
because God knows there was no point and
I think that actually is the point of
the Monday morning podcast for all you
people out there you know who tend to
take it unbelievably seriously those of
you out there who think that I
influenced the [ __ ] election is that
hilarious seven billion dollars was
spent to get Trump and all these [ __ ]
people a chance to get elected but you
know that all goes out the window
the second some [ __ ] who can't even
read out loud it does a podcast all out
the window I'll tell you if that's true
I'm gonna start I'm gonna start charging
more for my [ __ ] advertising you know
what I mean maybe I'll use that as a
selling point 2017 uh evidently I was I
was the recent Trump got into [ __ ]
office oh Jesus hey hey Trump support is
he liking what you seeing so far huh
you liking these [ __ ] you know you
thought Trump was old look at the
[ __ ] people he surrounded himself
with Jesus Christ if they're not in a
Nazi [ __ ] movie they're like 450
[ __ ] years old Rudy Giuliani this is
like when some old hair metal band gets
back together again thinking they're
gonna put out a [ __ ] relevant album
you're not it's over you had your time
it's [ __ ] done you know what I mean
these guys are gonna get the [ __ ] bad
back together and start singing about
what huh girls in a strip club and the
devil maybe the PMRC or whatever the
[ __ ] people used to sing about back in
the day I don't pretend to know you know
we will [ __ ] either way all these
[ __ ] people by the way I got to give
a shout-out to somebody what's her name
from Cosmopolitan magazine Laura Beck
calling out SNL for the horseshit that
that was that was that opening
completely agreed when they was saying
that the woman who plays Clinton Hillary
Clinton played Alleluia
it was kind of confusing like is was
this a tribute to [ __ ] Leonard Cohen
dying or what was this a political
[ __ ] statement and she kind of called
him out go
did you guys have Trump as a [ __ ]
host while he was running for president
and all of a sudden you know you help
promote the guy didn't you I mean [ __ ]
if I did by trashing both [ __ ] people
right
she actually said it was [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] hilarious it's a great read I'll
give you guys a link to it but I mean
it's a TV show that's what they do they
did that to a buddy man I did that the
[ __ ] Dane Cook they had him [ __ ]
host it twice he made him a bunch of
[ __ ] money with high ratings and then
all of a sudden there's a little blip on
the [ __ ] Internet you know tide turns
a little bit and then they use him as a
[ __ ] cheap joke when he wasn't even
he wasn't even on the show that's what
they do over there that's what they do
in this business they're not your
[ __ ] friends see that's why you know
what you do you stay where I stay right
my little cave you do a podcast by
yourself and then no one can hurt you
anyways so I every time I do is stand-up
special um you know it ends up being a
little bit too long at least the last
couple ones so you start thinking what
if you take this out here what if we do
a little [ __ ] thing here we've to do
and you end up [ __ ] the whole thing
up what you really have to do is you
just got it you got to cut off a limb
you know you got to remove a kidney
basically you just got to take out a
chunk and I figured out what chunk it
was gonna be or I had an idea that
that's what I wanted and then the
director Jay had the same idea we took
it out and it flows and it went from a
too long of a special now it's like
[ __ ] perfect
and now we're gonna and and all I've
seen at this point is just the raw feed
of it so it's not even like an HD and it
looks way over lit and on my [ __ ]
pasty goddamn white head I look like an
[ __ ] and it still looks like a good
special so I'm very excited I got that
done f is for family second season we're
starting to [ __ ]
you know tighten these things down for
the final [ __ ] edit and then then next
month I'm gonna start the process of
which should be a quick edit is editing
the audio from what I did Madison Square
Garden a year ago for the New York
Comedy Festival sorry hiccups New York
Comedy Festival I didn't almost get
emotional their New York Comedy Festival
OOP and then if once I get I get all
that [ __ ] done right then I'm just like
done I'm done I can just enjoy the rest
of the [ __ ] year I got nothing to do
really right and then then it starts all
over again in January you know it'd be
nice if I did cardio for the rest so we
can just you know then I can [ __ ]
throw down that's another good thing
about going to somebody's place for the
holidays they gotta clean up you know
you don't leave with a bunch of [ __ ]
food it's gonna be good
I'm excited above when he wants me to
make this [ __ ] stuff and I knew she
wouldn't let me just go over there it's
like why can't I just be the 12 pack guy
you know that's the best guy you put on
a sweater right you go over there you
make people [ __ ] laugh you show up
with like a 12 a [ __ ] whatever
whatever the [ __ ] you want you know I
tried this IPA lately I'm really not an
IPA guy I go in and out of that [ __ ] I
usually drink just drink [ __ ] that's
considered a white trash beer and
because I just like getting [ __ ] you
know not under the tastes
I just won't get [ __ ] up right and
then what you guys just say well those
IPAs have a [ __ ] high alcohol content
I don't give a [ __ ] that [ __ ] they're
heavy [ __ ] heavy as hell but I tried
this one it was called the green light
and I got it I don't even because they
only had a couple beers at this place it
was this foofy [ __ ] place and I just
wanted a beer and there was that's one
of the only ones they had I actually
really liked it I mind me living in
Boston [ __ ] going out to [ __ ]
Chestnut Hill and the green light dope
Kenmore Square go to the [ __ ] Sox
Gary Allison oh Jesus there's a couple
of Red Sox names from way back in the
day anyways I tried that [ __ ] I actually
really liked it
I don't want about you guys I'm just
[ __ ] talking in circles because I
haven't been home I haven't been in my
house and like [ __ ] two months and
I've had it me and me have been living
on top of each other and you know I
don't know about her but I'm pretty sick
of us being this close to one another so
hopefully Tuesday we get back in the
[ __ ] place oh nice [ __ ] throw
Aaron Rodgers over the top DB complain
and say it he [ __ ] pushed off course
you're gonna say that that's what you
say when a guy [ __ ] what a tight end
Beach of that deep is a [ __ ] corner
how the hell does that happen how do you
let that happen I asked you guys they
pushed him within five yards I think
that was alright um anyways how about
those Bruins huh handle in Winnipeg I
was all nervous they're the top two
scorers in the league what do we do we
put [ __ ] three of them three goals in
the second period right who scored
[ __ ] my shy and [ __ ] Bergy belsky
whatever the [ __ ] his name is and then I
don't know the [ __ ] sweets will you
actually went up for enough of one four
to one
that's another thing when I get back I
got my Bruins and Celtics package I can
start watching that [ __ ] so I can really
start boring you guys with the sports
talk you know I didn't see the Patriots
game today cuz I've been running around
I haven't been spending time with my
wife so I took her out someplace today
she'll come on later tell you all about
it and but all I know is it's a usual
[ __ ] all my [ __ ] friends who are Pats
fans like dude why did we trade Chandler
Jones why'd we get rid of Jamie Collins
I [ __ ] defense tanks toad so I think
it was you know what should have been an
easy game I guess evidently wasn't but I
didn't see any of that I watched the
boxing though who the [ __ ] that Russian
guy that Eagle RER enough was that his
[ __ ] name whoever was a real hockey
Russian name was Sergey Kovalev which is
like every Russian guy in the NHL easy
this first name is Sergey or his last
name is Cole that's really like the John
Smith of Russian names so he's fighting
this American dude so I got to go for
the [ __ ] American and I got to tell
you something
the [ __ ] first first [ __ ] round
alright
ego Larionov comes out and he [ __ ]
punches Andre Reed was that the guy's
name was that the guy in the bills I
can't [ __ ] remember I'm not a big
boxing fan I love the sport I love it
but it's been ruined it's been ruined
because every three pounds is a new
weight class that has yet another
[ __ ] champion and then there's like
15 different [ __ ] boxing federations
it's a [ __ ] show like there's more
boxing divisions than there are podcasts
and I'll tell you that same because
there's a lot you know to me when I was
a kid it was like it was like flyweight
it was like flyweight featherweight
middleweight welterweight heavyweight
something like that I can't remember I
can't remember the [ __ ] divisions now
I have things like there's like 15
offshoots of each one of them it's you
know what it's like those superhero
movies like back in the day like
Superman was in a Superman movie Batman
was in a bet he didn't [ __ ] know each
other they weren't all hanging out at
the same place maybe on the super
friends they were super friends they did
at the Hall of Justice but they they
only did that they did that when they
drew it but they never had that in
movies you don't I mean Superman was
Christopher Reeves that was his [ __ ]
[ __ ] and see Batman right who they have
they had Michael Keaton remember that
and he was all sweaty in the locker room
with just a towel around him wearing the
bat mask and he got in the face of Val
Kilmer and he was like that's right
Iceman
I am dangerous and then Val said clicked
his [ __ ] teeth together and then they
all played volleyball you know and then
they were playing volleyball
Aquaman didn't come out of the ocean
Teddy you know what I mean
look at a Batman being like take my
breath away
do you know kelly mcgillis gets in her
invisible jet I can't remember the I
can't believe the [ __ ] names I
remember from that movie I saw that
movie a bunch of times that was one that
I owned on VHS
when tank tank tank of uncle bunk bunk
right I was in high school and everybody
wouldn't wanted to get a [ __ ] ninja
motorcycle and [ __ ] fly f-16s you
know inverted we all thought we were
going to do that you know
this every once in a while like a movie
comes out and you're like you know what
I'm gonna [ __ ] do that right and then
what happens you know what happens
geometry algebra two and trig all of
that happens and then you're like oh oh
wait a minute wait I thought out I think
I was gonna fly chances that what I
thought was gonna happen oh I'm sorry
I'm gonna be a Salesman you know I make
people laugh you know I you know I might
come into a room I make people feel good
anyway you got a product I'll do it huh
but you second cotton potatoes like this
what if you had that I like the guy with
the John Reagan's [ __ ] Jersey in the
crowd at the Redskins game n44 was
always a badass [ __ ] number that was
always a fullback number when I was
growing up John Riggins Robert Newhouse
you know Chuck Foreman if he was a
running back was he 44 that was a badass
[ __ ] number Reggie Jackson you know
know this guy Starks he's gotta live
that said that's a [ __ ] legendary
number whatever Eddie [ __ ] Hall of
Famers were 44 I had [ __ ] that well
how many [ __ ] just like skirts were
44 not a lot everybody ever wore 44 was
a tough [ __ ] right I like to
think John Reagan's broke my heart man
cuz I was a big-time Cowboys fan back
then before how about cowboy when they
kicked out Tom Landry and Tex Schramm
that was just the worst you know I
thought Tom Landy was gonna be there
forever you know I was young I didn't
know I didn't know people get old and it
passes a by it's [ __ ] up right and I
hated the [ __ ] Redskins for beating
the Cowboys so much that when they were
in that Super Bowl actually rooting for
the Dolphins and I hated the [ __ ]
dolphins cuz we could never beat him and
when Riggins broke through the line and
whoever the [ __ ] that was on the
Dolphins that came by and just grabbed
him by the waist and slid down him like
a greased [ __ ] pole they just kept
running that dad killed me
was it a J Dewey I don't [ __ ]
remember anyways um how much time if I'd
done here's the time for the [ __ ]
reads yet I don't think so
hey Nia you want to come in here and
tell people about your day I got to tell
you this [ __ ] right so I haven't been
you know I've been [ __ ] busting my
ass you know it's getting ready to this
special and then editing all that
[ __ ] I talked about earlier so you
know if you don't spend time with your
wife all of a sudden your wife gets all
upset with you like oh you don't spend
time with me and boo-hoo-hoo I have
[ __ ] needs hey Nia I'm just I'm doing
a character what the [ __ ] did I do with
the mic it is the microphone hey is the
microphone all right hello talk to me
hello talk to me goose hello
so anyways yeah I haven't been spending
time with you so I figured today you
know what I got to go I got to do
something I got to do something so yeah
I took my wife to go see Casablanca
today while the Patriots were on I got
to get credit for that okay so I thought
it was at this old theater I was telling
you about these guys on I think Thursday
I was tell him about it like those
there's all these old theaters out here
that I'm obsessed with where they had
the Oscars throughout the years yeah I
just think of all the great you know
comedians and actors and directors and
everything they've been on well I love
that sense of history right so you got
the Pantages you got the [ __ ] who's
the more what's out in Santa Monica
Kodak Theatre all these [ __ ] places
so I just remember that one from the 80s
that I always saw I guess it was in
downtown LA maybe that's the one down
the other way I don't [ __ ] know but I
just looked him up and I was like you
know what I'd love to do maybe a show
there or I might want to do you know
just go to something and I looked up
that one downtown and it said there was
just a bunch of orchestras there and
then I said it was Casablanca I'm like a
[ __ ] love Humphrey go Bogart I'll
take Nia to go see that [ __ ] so we go
down and of course we show up in the
theater I want to go into there's nobody
there they're like oh yeah yeah it's not
here it's it's at the theater next
a little old couple so you go up and I'm
we're walking around the theater it's
completely deserted I'm already starting
to car some [ __ ] storm yeah bills
already getting hot
I'm gonna [ __ ] that it was on the
[ __ ] website I looked it up I looked
it up twice I did a couple who are
walking with their little bonnets on yup
cuz it was raining outside yeah bill
asked like who is this where they have
in the movie I was a little more frantic
than that yeah so you got you guys come
from the movie year old that was my
energy across the street at the the
concert home and you had a you're one of
your classic you you you made the
mistake and so you start having a little
meltdown I didn't make a mistake
cuz if you look the [ __ ] theater up
and you look at that anyhow later ok and
it says it was at the Dorothy Chandler
Pavilion no you click on calendar events
and then it's just it lists and it lists
that but I think the same person owns
the theater it's very [ __ ] you know
it's like buying a car
yeah we got it this lot and all of a
sudden you down the street it's like
you're in Goodfellas a little further
down I don't know Jimmy I think I'll
pick it up tomorrow that's what they did
to me well anyway it was across the
street at the Walt Disney Concert
symphony looking thing that looks like a
[ __ ] exploded golf ball designed by
Frank Gehry it's like one of the most
like impressive it's like the drummer
from extreme isn't it no it's a very
famous architect a blank go black
what you see here get the funk out get
the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out get the
funk out what do you think we won't try
to it's one of the whitest trying to be
funky songs ever get the funk out that
one and then there's the some big joan
is my name anyway lady building what
game it's basil wars this building was
one of the most like impressive you know
pieces of architecture in los angeles
it's a beautifully designed space and
bill is just like
I couldn't help but laugh a hooka
Stewart says muttering and cursing and
stomping around in the rain I hate that
super-modern [ __ ] I've done shows and
those stupid Symphony [ __ ] things you
feel like you're in front of like the
council and one of those Superman movies
well you're like down there all [ __ ]
up above you and they're behind you
I [ __ ] hate those things so it's like
I don't want to [ __ ] go into this
thing so I end up showing but it's like
I got to take out of this thing it's
[ __ ] raining out so me is all like
well we could go to that theater another
time what it's a Division I into like
calm you down because it's an aisle
we're going to another building no big
deal you know we're gonna go see Kay and
then what happened we go we show so we
show up and I go hey can I get and I
literally said you go now we're gonna
[ __ ] go to this stupid ass [ __ ]
theater it's probably in some small room
it's gonna be you me and four other old
people and the movies the movies almost
ready to start right so we [ __ ] show
up and I go up to the booth and I go
yeah I need two tickets to Casablanca
and the person's like oh I don't know if
there's any tickets left like what are
you talking about it's raining it's
Sunday football's on his [ __ ] movies
like 80 years old and who's gonna come
see like I got a check right and then
she finally goes well you can't actually
be found - I'm like thank Christ trying
to do something romantic here it's not
the right [ __ ] theater now they're
gonna be sold out she goes you got to go
down to Windows so I say fine I kept my
cool there man right the rain had rain
enough on my steaming head that I walked
over it cools you off a little bit
pulled me up a little bit now welcome I
go let me get to and I they go okay and
then they go the guy goes okay that's
gonna be a hundred and sixty one dollars
right I go one hundred sixty one dollars
he goes each so it turned out no way so
this is what it turned it turns out I
think this is way too loud here I can't
turn this down here it turns out that
what was happening was the LA
Philharmonic was gonna be playing the
film score while you watched
turns out this is a major la cultural
event that was basically just gonna be
in the movie raining for a few other
people and us it's this major event
every got on like sport coats [ __ ]
dresses and shoes rest I'm so there my
wet hoodie Humphrey Bogart in there what
the [ __ ] going on right we're gonna
deal with the view the body
Aaron Eckhart and like introduces the
[ __ ] movie yes so you know you know
when you just don't give a [ __ ] I just
said [ __ ] it so I light up the card and
I go let's go in then and I start
getting this feeling of like this might
be might this might be [ __ ] amazing
and then there's all these uh shoes walk
around hitting these things that are
going letting people know that you know
that whole like you don't to disturb
rich white people that the things about
ready to start
whatever that [ __ ] instrument is
called and they [ __ ] go in there we
go in there and in like it's like holy
[ __ ] like we're gonna listen to it the
LA Philharmonic while we watched
Casablanca and now how [ __ ] great was
it was amazing it was such an awesome
experience so bill kind of fumbled it
fumbled his way into a really amazing
slim romantic day and I get no credit I
get no credit because I picked the wrong
[ __ ] theatre I just totally stopped I
can't you be like how you see that with
the orchestra I feel like you definitely
get points for you seeing that you saw
something culture going on you're like
oh that sounds cool like Nene would like
that and we went and it turned out to be
amazing so yes it was great yeah Aaron
it was a Hail Mary it wasn't even a Hail
Mary
yeah we the actor came out and
introduced the movie or not the oil man
is there another famous Aaron Eckhart I
don't know are you being sarcastic I'm
being a dick right now was he and no
[ __ ] was he nope no country old man he
was in there get out of here [ __ ] in
the company of men uh yeah him and he
was in Sully Sully yeah yeah the
mustache yes
in that movie it was in that movie which
well that was a movie that was a movie
they made up that made evidently they
made up all of this other's [ __ ] he was
so [ __ ] boring can I just say that
you don't have to say it I'll say ah
come on it's a nice word it was rap for
tenet Jerry's in it it's a bunch of yes
we have friends that are in that movie
but now are we a Hollywood couple our
friends are in it that movie was so
boring because you know why
because nobody this is Sun sounds so
terrible but nobody died nobody got
knowing yogurt like it was nailed it he
put it right where he was supposed to
put it yeah there's no both my engines
went out at 1500 feet should I try to
land it in the water or fly back over
the most densely populated area in the
United States so you put it in the water
everyone survived the whole thing took
in real life 24 minutes for everyone to
get rescued it's like what is the movie
about it well they had to have them
happy you got to have the evil corporate
guys going you couldn't save the jet
yeah could you push some people out on
the way over it just wasn't exciting Tom
Hanks's is it is a wonderful actor
although acting was great in it I want
to see to play a serial killer I'm so
sick I am always being doing the right
thing
that's not his brand that's not Tom
Hanks his brand he's not a serial killer
did he die in Saving Private Ryan
spoiler alert remember he was just
firing at the tank you never saw that no
it's not my night into those kind of I'm
not mean it's a war movies the Sun a war
movie Saving Private Ryan is not about a
war no in soldiers that died in it well
I mean that's literally what it but it's
more of a metaphor it is yeah Saving
Private Ryan isn't meant as a metaphor
yeah what is it a metaphor for a plane
it's don't even know what you're talking
about
it's an incredible [ __ ] movie all
right and I believe you all right we
kind of just killed your credibility
just say sally's boring and then you're
like yeah I'm not into war movie Saving
Private Ryan almost unbelievable [ __ ]
movies ever saw why does that kill my
credibility just because I didn't like
because I said so oh I see that's how it
works one thing has to do with the other
I don't know you you've been bugging me
lately y-yeah I don't know I just I
don't wanna be a dick but are you
putting on weight
excuse me you're like putting on weight
every [ __ ] month you getting bigger
like ya keep telling you the [ __ ] bow
do something about it
I I have a condition you have a
condition one second makes me bigger and
bigger every month I was having a baby
laugh factory [ __ ] tweeted that out
so I guess we gotta announce it yeah I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] father we're gonna be
parents everybody so excited for us
do you notice they don't give a [ __ ] I'm
actually people people who have you know
who you are already today offline stay
offline don't become that person I feel
like people care listen why cuz it's
gonna bring out all the people who have
nasty things to say about it no cuz
people have lives but people have been
actually been very sweet what what what
no you know you're watching those
[ __ ] those ladies screaming at each
other too much and the ones where they
sit around you know wasn't one of funny
things I saw lately was when you you had
the [ __ ] Kardashians on with the
sound down yeah so much of the footage
as them just looking each other with
their [ __ ] mouths kind of open like
slack-jawed because someone else is
talking over the top just going I just
feel like when Mandy said to Sandy that
she you know she couldn't go during the
nose job trip I felt that she was upset
and whereas the person's talking they
just cut to their faces and like do I
can't it's official they look like those
little pouty cats okay
I mean okay no I just want you to turn
this into a Kelly Ripa moment guys
and this is what would wear just makes
me feel like you know I'm starting
understand why Michael Strahan left that
show so anyways yeah it's official it is
confirmed all right and I'm just gonna
not gonna do all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're very you know you're like you're
progressing Lee talking about and I
understand why I don't know cuz I
[ __ ] hate parents
you hate man I hate and like why the
ones on no you know this is the hardest
[ __ ] job yeah the most rewarding job
like blah blah blah and you know and
then they all say it they all [ __ ] even
like Chuck Yeager would say some [ __ ]
like that it's like really dude flying a
[ __ ] jet up into space like trying to
get a kids [ __ ] backpack on for first
grade is is more difficult than what the
[ __ ] you just went through up there you
know what I mean I think that they
placate the [ __ ] is that the right
word to Joe Sixpack well they got but
the real heroes pander pander the real
people love the real heroes out there
the people out there they're there
they're there making the tuna fish
sandwiches gotta get it into four
[ __ ] pieces you had sex and you
didn't use protection all right you're
not Tom Hanks pretending to land a
[ __ ] plane into the Hudson River okay
you did it's not exactly the Miracle on
the Hudson so old Billy booze bags gonna
get a cut more right to left in before
the gluts the little one comes and then
I'm gonna be I got a big guy gonna be so
I gotta pick my spots that is that is
that the idea is that's what's been
happening that you've just gonna go on
and like a little bit of a bender
yeah bender the whole [ __ ] year and
then when the baby comes you're gonna
just like cut yourself off yeah I mean
what am i until maybe [ __ ] hungover
and we'll be that guy no I hope not
ya know I'm not gonna do that no it's
it's it's over it's done but then I got
I got all this great hooch back at the
house so I gotta kill it I gotta kill it
before it comes you have to like drink
all the alcohol before the baby it's not
like you're never gonna have it but I
got to make space for like [ __ ] sippy
cups and [ __ ] don't
that word a word a word sucking my
bottles down they're not gonna go on the
bar you know what I'll save some of my
Pappy Van Winkle's we had morning the
most spoiled kid ever when the baby's
teething I'll rub Pappy Van Winkle's on
it's what it's [ __ ] gums yeah isn't
that what you're supposed to do I don't
know I don't know that like that's an
old-school thing but I'm already gonna
do this [ __ ] like every time the kid
cries I'm not [ __ ] going in there I'm
gonna there's this great book that I
read on Norwegian parenting that says
that you know when the kid starts crying
you just you just kind of you know you
creep up to the bed and then you kind of
look and he just go and then that's it
you scared the [ __ ] out of it and it
understands what's going on you're
making fun of what I told you within the
book that I'm reading by the way it's
2924 [ __ ] Washington rebate just
scored this is a great game this reminds
me when those old San Diego tragic games
while you're doing the podcast I don't
know I just saw it so that's not a push
in the back get the [ __ ] out of here
anyways what were you talking about oh
you having a kid the biggest moment in
our relationship ever
you know well let's see what happens yes
we've been going to like [ __ ] Lamaze
classes and [ __ ] yes in Christ the
classes have been great the classes have
been great but this is how far the
[ __ ] progressives left has gone
there's a [ __ ] line for when she
comes in it says mom will you sign up
and me I'm thinking finally a name of
mother name of mother and then I'm like
and then my column like I'm finally
gonna be called a dad after almost
living on this planet behalf a [ __ ]
century it just says partner [ __ ]
ridiculous and what kills me is
everybody in their heterosexual all in a
[ __ ] relationship everybody there was
was it was all straight couples straight
couples and all the dads were there yeah
yeah that's true let's just keep going
coaches telling them coach
I swear to god dude I'm gonna show up
with a [ __ ] whistle next week the
[ __ ] Bill Belichick hoodie and
shipped the [ __ ] are you talking about
she said I bet I did
probably gonna get in trouble she said
dad's twice last class I didn't hear it
yeah too busy muttering under your
breath Abed
every time she says coaches I say
fathers forefathers I'm not trying to
cut out gay people or people who got
bagged behind a [ __ ] Carl's jr. you
know what I mean but what about us
that's the solution I thought it's
inclusive he's supposed to include
people I'll take second a third billing
behind alternative people what did you
think of that um birthing video that we
watched the last class
Oh Polly's placenta yeah that was
tremendous I don't know I don't know why
I'm there Nia it's all gonna go out the
[ __ ] window the doctors and nurses
are gonna tell you what to do I'm just
there for you [ __ ] yell at me
it's so [ __ ] stupid if I was going
through gallbladder surgery or whatever
you would not be in there holding my
[ __ ] hand it's so dumb this is just
classic you guys you know you got you
got the [ __ ] end of the stick on this
thing and somehow you figured out a way
to drag us in there I'll tell you right
now I'm staying north of that [ __ ]
sheet yeah when that guy comes in and
goes hey the Shay you want to hook up
your own cable no I don't that's what
the [ __ ] I'm paying you for
I don't want you to be below the blanket
below deck you know needs to be full of
performance problems for the next three
months cuz I keep picturing my kid's
head coming out of your watch now I'm
not doing this I shouldn't be in there
you might [ __ ] it in mash after you
watch the movie you leaned over to me
and you said I understand now why the
guy is in there you did he had to get
yelled up no that's not what it was it
was to provide comfort yeah you're
killing my [ __ ] image here okay so
stop showing your image
[ __ ] your image no so I want to be yeah
I'm gonna be sober debt but on the road
hold up ten ripping it up you know yeah
oh just like every other comic out there
you [ __ ] hack I told you my last
podcast I was going for a Boston accent
word and I realized that I was gonna get
in trouble if I said it but I had to
switch the [ __ ] I was like I'll talk to
you ladies like one cells like yeah it's
a new day I'm gonna get in trouble if I
say to me I don't mean anything by it so
yeah any ones don't end up like Kanye
don't everybody be mad at you well he's
gonna be fine he knows what the [ __ ]
he's doing he was yelling I'll be honest
with India I don't understand those
shows anyways there's no band
everybody's standing with their cell
phones on and there's somebody rapping
and then they just sticking them it's
it's for young kids they love it and I'm
not gonna go there like I'm not gonna be
that guy I stay away from them I'm gonna
go see Casablanca in the ring with a
bunch of old people by the way Nia yes
did you see during the break those old
people trying to walk holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
I cannot stress stretching and getting a
massage if he can afford to do it once a
month at all she's and there was a
hunched over people yeah a lot of people
roughly my [ __ ] age to having limps
and [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] did you guys
do you know look some of them probably
fought in a [ __ ] war who's kidding no
but I'm just saying speaking get on to
me I know maybe we should give him a
break they didn't all fight the [ __ ]
war you don't mean they weren't all on
the front lines as I'm saying a lot of
people with peanut potatoes and they're
still [ __ ] limping that makes no
sense all right let me let me read a
little bit of advertising peeling
potatoes there all right blue apron
everybody you know Nia I don't know if
you realize this but not all ingredients
are created equal
blasts all right Donald Trump's gonna
become president this is what copies
gonna look like now
fresh high-quality white ingredients
does it make make a real difference so
it's important to know where your food
comes all right affordable for less than
$10 per person per meal blue apron
delivers seasonal recipes along with
pre-portion ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals choose from
a variety of new recipes each week or
let blue aprons culinary team surprise
you recipes are not repeated with any
years so you'll never get bored
you've flexible you can customize your
recipes each week based on your
preferences blue apron has several
delivery options so you can choose the
one that fits your needs and there's no
weekly commitments they only get
deliveries when you want them each meal
comes with a step-by-step easy-to-follow
recipe card and pre-portion of greens
and can be guaranteed in 40 minutes or
less blue aprons freshness guarantees
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron comm slash burg
you'll love how good it feels
and taste to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait that's blue apron calm / /
blue apron a better way to cook oh here
we go everybody but who do me andhis me
undies no more sweaty nuts but no more
sweaty berries that switch it up right
yeah start it take to me undies be
undies no more sweaty berries but throw
me under Smee undies you're falling off
a [ __ ] fairy you go into the water
your balls are still dry along comes a
stingray puts out your eye but you
could've died like the crocodile hunter
I bet he wasn't wearing me undies when
he got stabbed there sorry I'm sorry
Australia now me undies picture a world
we're putting on a new pair of underwear
isn't just fresh you're stepping into a
better day think about it underwear is
the first thing you put on and the last
thing you take off unless you're [ __ ]
weird
alright no you know what we have a deal
if not like I say that you know what if
you really have to just take a [ __ ] you
just [ __ ] like you have to [ __ ] so
bad you bypass
doing your belt and undoing your pants
you just [ __ ] you know you give you
you give yourself the old right there
Fred yanking it all down you know that's
not true most most people when they get
arrested only thing they have on you
know that's not true you don't have a
shirt there has been times we just have
on a t-shirt is it anyways why would you
settle for anything less than the best
feeling underwear on the planet well
because maybe yeah you have different
priorities I don't know please include
the following points during your read
well if you write it I'm gonna [ __ ]
read it the undies focuses solely on
producing the most comfortable underwear
you've ever experienced my friends at me
undies sent me a few pairs at and now I
can't imagine wearing anything else it
really makes each day that much better
stop putting words in my [ __ ] mouth
yeah they're comfortable but a few of
them were way too [ __ ] a little racy
for me you know what I mean
the Greg Louganis cuts there for the
price of two cocktails me undies will
deliver your new pair of favorite
underwear right to you right to your
doorstep better day guaranteed you try
them on a few that are not the most
comfortable best feeling undies you've
ever had and they'll refund you and let
you keep your first pair for free
including it in the price is the sweet
touch of modal modal a special fabric
made of the best-in-class raw materials
that are evidently scientifically proven
to be three times softer than cotton
these uber cozy undies are sold
exclusively on the me undies website
where you'll enjoy free shipping in US
and Canada everybody else can go [ __ ]
themselves and for a limited time
everyone in my audience gets 20% off
their first order but you have to go to
our special you are URL me undies
dot-com / / with me undies it's a better
day guaranteed you have nothing to lose
so don't wait any longer go to me undies
dot-com / / right now for 20% off your
first order that's me unease calm / /
all right how many we got left all right
we got two quick ones left can you hang
in there alright simply safe everybody
if it's a safe place you're making this
not a safe place I'm gonna wear a safety
pin simply safe ever find yourself
almost all the way to work or maybe
you're you're out with your family and
friends and you get that nagging feeling
did I close the window did I lock that
door
why did I [ __ ] the maid why did I [ __ ]
the maid the kids going to look like me
sorry it's a Schwarzenegger reference
you just don't know it can drive you
nuts there well you don't have to worry
about it when you got simply safe home
security well if you left the [ __ ]
window open you can't set the ligate he
can't set the alarm okay
it's a nice extra layer of protection so
now simply safe is there simply safe has
an arsenal of sensors to protect your
entire family your entire home and keep
your family safe simply safe got rid of
everything that makes most homes secure
home security such a pain there's no
long-term contracts no hidden feeds they
won't gouge it's $14.99 a month that's
three times less than what other
companies charge and about 150 dollars
less than I paid for a [ __ ] movie
ticket today and here's some big news
simply safe has just released its
brand-new high-definition security
camera this camera is different you know
what's great about that you can actually
see the criminals face you know instead
of having it all pixelated out you can
actually look me like is that my
neighbor this camera is different it
connects directly to your security
system and since your sense to it to
your smartphone a smartphone video the
second something happens at your home
what the [ __ ] that's crazy
you can see everything that's going on
so you don't have to wonder anymore do
that means you're gonna be out at the
restaurant right and you're just gonna
be eating and all of a sudden some
random customs be like dude what the
[ __ ] yeah right freak it out instead of
just calling the cops I don't know what
you do check out simply safes new camera
today I'll do that would be sickening
you know you see them grabbing like your
favorite [ __ ] [ __ ] out of the house
just go to simply safe burg calm right
now that's simply safer calm simply save
bird calm and filing Thea come on in MV
MT watches pronounced movement was
founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank
yeah you should listen to this yeah what
they just said that's suppose a man this
means you spend too much [ __ ] money
you know exactly what it means no don't
play dumb with me what you can't mean
here to attack me I was now so you
complete the effort sexy
yeah I was gonna come back when you're
done yeah and I subtly Sherman I subtly
gave you [ __ ] and then you pull the
emergency brake and now here we are okay
everybody knows once again style
shouldn't break the bank the watchmakers
goal is to change the way consumers
think about fashion by offering
high-quality minimalist products at
revolutionary prices Nia I hear you with
over 500,000 watches sold to customers
in 160 countries around the world
movement watches has just solidified
itself as the world's fastest growing
watch company Mubin watches start at
just $95 at a department store you're
looking at four to five hundred bucks
neiha movement figured out by by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman in retail markup providing the
best possible price classic to the
designs quality construction and styled
minimalism over 500,000 watches sold in
over 160 countries get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to movement watches dot-com / /
that's MV MT watches comm / / this watch
has a really clean design seriously
okay you're gonna get a lot of
compliments if you wear this watch now
is the time to step up your game go to
mV mt watches comm / / join the movement
alright you want to answer a few
questions before we get the [ __ ] out of
here sure before we get the [ __ ] outta
here
what's the score to the game Nia right
and I myself that watch that I have by
the way huh I didn't say you did he just
taken the bait me I'm just breaking your
[ __ ] ovaries over there what does
this go to the [ __ ] game I'll just
shown the highlights alright hey there
Billy Claire voyant you probably didn't
notice this because I doubt you you
listen back to your own podcast but
there have been throwback paralyzed I
actually listened to my podcast as I
upload them I just listening to him you
know I don't know why I do him he loves
the sound of his own voice that's not
true I've learned to love it when you
first hear your own voice you don't like
it now I can't live without it
I work around with headphones my house
just listening to my own podcast
when Andrew cuts together the clips he
uses the same date from eight years ago
last Thursday was from November 17th
oh he told me does it that's cool he
said in that episode you made a
reference to Cash Cab which was hosting
which was hosted by your guest this week
Ben Bailey also a couple weeks ago when
you first mentioned watching Westworld
the throwback clip had you mentioned the
original Westworld
once again eight years ago to the day
yeah that back then that's when I wanted
to buy the rights to it until I realized
it was zillions of dollars and I was
like oh forget it
bye-bye everybody I had my whole
representation all excited like he's
gonna do something like this we can get
a piece of this and I was like oh that's
too much money he said I'll be on the
lookout for more of these in hopes to
exploit your magic love you love Nia
well that's all love you too boo that's
all due to what's-his-face
Andrew Andrew like I think he tries to
find like the parallel so that's his
homework not mine all right Thanksgiving
recipe hey there Billy white meat I like
that Billy white boy the other white
meat the other white meat hey there
Billy white meat uh what are you going
to teach us to cook this year if I don't
get another cooking video like the pie
crust masterpiece I'm boycotting the
season I'm the single one of my siblings
and last year I showed up with the pie
and waited so everyone was done to let
them know I made it then I showed them
your video and we had some full bully
belly laughs full I mean full belly
laughs is what you want to say don't let
me make don't let me make let my family
down
don't let me let my family down by
letting me down okay
thanks for all the free labs hearing you
get through that's it I know my eyes are
always ten words ahead of what I can
[ __ ] remember I think that's what
happened so maybe I'm just dumped it's
gonna be sad when our kids a better
reader than me [ __ ] it's six months in
he's gonna teach you how to read I'm
gonna read you some book and oh yeah
whenever I read to like my nieces and
nephews like there's a point when they
stop looking at the book and they just
turn around and look at me and then it's
like more pressure him and I'm literally
reading like the rabbit goes hop hop hop
hop it doesn't go hop it hops a cow goes
Moo maybe that helps you out there
[ __ ] old it bald well I feel like
last year like making a pie crust was
like a real [ __ ] skill that I had
like I don't know what else to show you
guys how to make you know if Nia lets me
get this [ __ ] griddle that I want to
get oh my god this griddle oh my god
this [ __ ] griddle it's like you love
when I cook but you don't want to you
don't want to you know I mean it's like
you like your freedom but you don't want
to see how it happens you're the same
way with food you know
touchdown [ __ ] Redskins goddamn it
because I don't what are you trying to
do here you're trying to get like every
[ __ ] invention that has to do with
cooking or grilling or smoking or frying
you want to buy it and it's just like
where are we gonna put all this [ __ ]
okay let list all the [ __ ] that I've
bought I'm not saying that you've bought
it all I'm saying that you want to buy
it I don't know why I do want to buy it
all and why haven't I bought it all
because there's no room for it oh and
who determined that I mean who
determined that near I have you decided
that I thought it was a mutual it wasn't
alright I had a buddy mine was gonna
hook me up with this pellet smoker
you said no well because he tried to act
like he told me it was the size of a
typewriter he would be a soul and when
he actually showed us I mean he was like
come here let me show you let me show
you what it looks like and then I looked
at it and I'm like and what universe is
this the size of a typewriter the size
of like a sewing machine he goes oh yeah
yeah it's more like a sewing machine I'm
like a sewing machine is on a typewriter
can I tell you something here that's why
guys are great that's why I love that
dude forever because you know we do that
for each other I
of women - I won't speak for you guys
but guys do that for each other it was a
science it's the size of a wall you need
a kitchen the size of his kitchen in
order to do all the things that you want
to do yeah it's a kitchen it's a
portable thing it's on [ __ ] wheels
it's in the back but we got like three
[ __ ] tables in the backyard and I
can't get rid of any of those tables for
the [ __ ] potato salad you know every
piece of furniture I put in the backyard
has a function and we have used it in
that function doesn't mean no you know
what you're doing is you've become the
dictator of the [ __ ] backyard mmm
you're the woman I own the backyard I
own the [ __ ] garage if we had a
basement that's my [ __ ] you can have the
rest of the [ __ ] house all right so
what are you saying I'm saying I'm
getting that griddle okay all right
Jesus you're gonna say that until I
[ __ ] make you a nice [ __ ] steak
and cheese or make some hash browns or
make you a Grand Slam breakfast you've
been making all those things without the
griddle summated guy right so exactly so
what do you need all this other stuff
for if you're so talented cuz just
imagine how good it would taste if I
actually had a [ __ ] griddle even
those [ __ ] stoves that have a griddle
if the thing sucks because it's it's one
heat source so you can't you can't have
difference you can't move it around you
can't play with your heat it sucks it's
like this is the temperature it's a pain
in the [ __ ] ass that's one thing if
you got a pot or a pan you can take it
on the heat take it off when you're on
your [ __ ] griddle you know you want
one on one off and maybe one a little
bit on why don't you just get one of
those little electric grills
what am i a freshman in college once you
can put on your counter well when you
divorce me well that's too sad to say if
you ever do that man you ever do that
is a grown [ __ ] man to buy divorcee
kitchen products [ __ ] are you talking
about divorce yeah I'll go to McDonald's
and grab some extra packets of ketchup
for in the future when I need more
ketchup I've done all that Nia I've used
shares for tables they ate pasta all
[ __ ] day and pancakes I've done all
that yes I'm Donna Sui now yeah yeah yo
you sick of my self-made man [ __ ] it
annoys you doesn't it I would eat
spaghetti with the prego and and the
bread because it would fill me up and it
would last me all night that's right do
all my spots and I have any pancakes
because it kept me the most full and
filled me up like cement and you know
how I'm doing that for the [ __ ]
people out there women included who
wanna be wanna [ __ ] make something
happen and foods a big thing cuz you got
it [ __ ] have it every day so you got
to have that [ __ ] that fills you up
alright listen don't let this little ray
of sunshine [ __ ] rain on your parade
okay I'm here for all you guys I'm the
positive guy I'm the motivational
speaker hey speaking of motivational
what the [ __ ] going on with the p90x
guy if you become a vegan or something
well first of all he's not doing p90x
anymore he's got a different thing
late-night yeah yeah but now Tony Horton
he's looking a little like he's not
doing his pull-ups anymore he's getting
older he's looking like no he's looking
all veggie mmm-hmm anyways so I don't
know what I'm gonna make this year I
told you oh you mean for the for this
guy yeah yeah you want me to I'm not
showing my family secret family [ __ ]
recipe the best stuffing you're ever
gonna have
admit it most people's stuffing [ __ ]
sucker stuffing that bill makes oh my
god it's so delicious and I've never had
goods that's the only stuffing I've ever
had that even like it me too I don't
ever like stuffing roast it wet and it
already has that bad aftertaste yeah
this is nice and crispy and like buttery
oh it's so good yeah when you glad you
got that [ __ ] barbecue the other
night you didn't like the cornbread they
put that weird ingredient in there you
so and so read another question
dammit when the [ __ ] that I become such
a Packers fan there's just certain old
NFL teams I like I see like the Giants
can you [ __ ] believe that
than what they did to my Patriots twice
but One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest all
right hey they're all Billy Bibbit money
whose Bibbit there's a character I won
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest oh [ __ ]
what's-his-face downstairs yeah an old
friend of mine oh yeah has gone so far
down the rabbit hole of conspiracy
theories that he really can't even
function in society anymore huh that's
relatable tell him to start telling
jokes he's he is unable to hold a
conversation for two minutes without
going off on some rambling horseshit
about chemtrails freemasons aliens in
all of that crap completely oblivious to
the fact that none of us are interested
in hearing about all that nonsense he
reads on the Internet it used to be
funny we were driving out west a few
years back and he pointed out that some
lights moving up in the sky and said
those are the aliens that follow me
around oh oh this sounds like a mental
issue dude I said what does that sign on
the right said he said Airport next exit
and I said yeah those are airplanes you
jackass and he said well maybe some of
them Wow he goes okay it's been over a
decade of that kind of [ __ ] and it's
gotten way way worse because of this
obsession and the resulting paranoia he
can't even hold down a menial job and
all of his friends have abandoned ship
he become addicted to painkillers I
think he already had a mental issue yeah
of course has been in and out of rehab
centers in hospitals because of bizarre
health problems and it's now bordering
on full-blown schizophrenia well you
don't get that from reading conspiracy
theory sir yeah you really kind of
didn't [ __ ] quit here with that
question that whole thing in the
beginning was just like a red herring it
turns out he's got like serious mental
problems what's a red herring it's just
it's just a distraction
exactly it's something that you think is
the cause of you know I'm not gonna
explain it right cuz I'm tired but oh I
got use that excuse sometimes when I use
an expression that oh Jesus my brain
my brain is mush Christ how many points
this [ __ ] Aaron Rodgers got to put up
you know it's like Tom Brady the same
thing how many [ __ ] points to get a
score
it's gonna you know defense I want to
respect his right to believe what he
wants to believe but in the end it has
only caused him to lead an increasingly
miserable and lonely life that will end
in a tragedy and a sparsely attended
funeral unless something changes soon so
how the [ __ ] do you bring someone back
from so far over the edge okay well he
might be exaggerating a little bit with
the maybe he's using schizophrenia is
like a [ __ ] filler word they're like
you know this guy's a narcissist this
guy's a sociopath no but this sounds
like paranoid schizophrenia is exactly
Oh dr. hill are you gonna diagnose that
on this [ __ ] wonderful [ __ ]
unfortunately a member of my family who
went through this exact thing I do feel
that I recognize it a little bit yes as
a matter of fact I do okay but do you
feel like that you can make that
diagnosis as someone who is not a doctor
no is not a comedian is not even a
podcaster that you can find a podcast
done by a comedian as not a doctor
diagnosed this person that you've never
met based on this four paragraph email
to come in here so I'm giving my opinion
I thought you're gonna start a song to
come here are you annoyed that that lady
singing about all the ingredients you
get annoyed when black [ __ ] goes [ __ ]
mainstream and then white people ruin it
well I got peas greens tomatoes potatoes
that she I swear to God if that's what
my nice little week-long run before
everyone if that was my if that's what
my church was like I would I would go
every week if it was only a half-hour
long I still just can't get into the
[ __ ] I like the singing part in black
churches but even when the priests
regardless of race when they get up
there and they start saying that this
invisible guy gives a [ __ ] about me
that's I just I tap out I just can't
listen to it anyway Jesus Jesus want you
to have that
that's a stream down stay here friend
needs purchase help you're not gonna be
able a joel osteen he's a very positive
guy um well you know something he's been
out there long enough that you'd think
if there was a scandal it would come out
by now right mm-hmm
this your friend needs professional help
this is beyond your this is beyond your
pay grade Jesus don't [ __ ] on the guy he
might have just been being funny just
because I'm not [ __ ] on him I'm
saying that you're his friend needs help
and this is not anything that he is
qualified to do so cuz he that's not
much nicer way of saying things beyond
your pay grade hey buddy why don't you
get don't pick up your brother and keep
sweeping up this is the job of people
with lab coats but what does he see said
like I respects his right to believe
what he wants to believe but in the end
it yeah I don't I don't even think he
necessarily maybe even billions believes
that he's just got yeah he's yeah he's
become addictive pain Claire's have been
in and out of rehab centers and
hospitals because of bizarre health
problems yeah is now bordering on
full-blown schizophrenia yeah I think
you just got to be there for him but
maybe just check in on them and say hey
are you taking your meds are you going
to see your doctor that type of thing
but sure I don't think you're gonna be
able to like help him with this it's a
help yeah yeah you know it's [ __ ]
cool issue and the Redskins still have a
band and they actually have a team song
I think that's [ __ ] cool it's a
professional level for some reason that
all went away
I hope our baby doesn't get your ATD why
it's worked great for me have it yeah
yeah it is I played drums for
helicopters tell jokes you name a DD is
Phi is a [ __ ] great thing to have it
sucks with some [ __ ] but it's it's it
sucks when you're in school and you're
gonna do poorly in school and everyone's
gonna say you're [ __ ] dumb but when
you get out in the world man it's
[ __ ] tremendous it's tremendous
I know I run around all day don't have
it very so you don't have it like
severely though you are able to just
[ __ ] you just good you know you even
got the lab glasses on tonight though
you he's [ __ ] diagnosed and
everything how do you know what I have
it is remember when we tried to do that
ADT questionnaire and you couldn't even
pay attention to the question yeah
before I that was because I was annoyed
with it you want to revisit that real
quick no do an oldie but goodie all
right bill my kid is 14 years old 14
years old and he wants a drone for
Christmas the drone market is huge with
kids these days when I was a kid we
wanted to fly something for the sake of
flying it now they all have cameras
attached to them and they hover in a
real creepy way he's not a punk so he
won't flip out if he doesn't get one his
friends have them so it's not like he'll
he'd never used one if I did get him one
he's not the type of kid to fly it up to
someone's window so that's not the
concern I'm coming from a place like if
I didn't want him to get an earring more
of don't be that kid I might be
overreacting but that's just something
but there's just something about drones
what do you think Congrats on the
condition thank you I would say I agree
with you no drones no drones with the
cameras that's too much the [ __ ] I would
have [ __ ] done I would have the
hottest chick in the neighborhood I
would have had it out there Harvard
hover near a bathroom should be praised
yeah yeah
of course you would if he's not then his
friends are going to his friends are
gonna be like let's just take it over
here to see and this is a thing you know
that the person watching is jerking off
if it immediately crashes so kids are
really using drones like there are they
is that the hot gift this Christmas is a
drone for a teenager I mean it's it's an
amazing [ __ ] thing it really is I
mean I can't imagine like just flying
over a neighborhood to see what your
neighborhood looks like from the air or
your house all of that would be cool but
the the possibilities the [ __ ] that you
could do with those things in a with the
juvenile brain and I would be nervous
one of the best things my parents did
was they never let us play video games
they never let us play it they just you
not get net it's gonna [ __ ] with you
schoolwork you know as funny as I still
[ __ ] up in school but the great thing
is is I'm not a [ __ ] 48 year old
gamer you know like I just think that's
that's really like III you know I kind
of judge that [ __ ] like after a while
like like what are you what are you
doing you know what I mean don't you
want to go outside like the amount of
time that people spend you can learn a
language you can learn how to play an
instrument
it's um literally doing what every good
dolt says you could go out and do the
things that I find interesting the [ __ ]
if you're into video games go ahead and
play it but I'm glad that I didn't cuz I
waste enough time watching [ __ ]
sports I can't imagine cuz I told you
I've always said I tapped out after
Grand Theft Auto 3 it literally took
over my life I'm so sick of this [ __ ]
commercial where they show the Ford
f-150 with the aluminum bed and it has
it doesn't have any bed liner and they
drop the [ __ ] tool box into it and
then they show the Chevy with the steel
one this is such [ __ ] advertising
what it really is is I bet the Ford gets
better gas mileage because it has a
lighter bed and then all you do is just
put that the same rubber guard that
comes in all pickup trucks what kind of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] buys a pickup truck
and you don't have the bedliner the [ __ ]
out of here [ __ ] Chevy you know I like
this Silverado
alright Thanksgiving debacle Oh Billy
turkey legs
don't get your kid a drone if you don't
want them to have the drone you're the
you're the parent all right what's that
another a dd moment did I leave it there
I'm in a little debacle with my leg
about Thanksgiving I want my girl to
come to my Thanksgiving but it starts
like only an hour before hers I'm in a
little bit of a debauch for my lady
about Thanksgiving I want my girl to
come to my Thanksgiving but it starts
only an hour before hers but they are in
the same time town mind you mine's at my
aunt's house and hers is at her parents
mine starts at 12 her starts at 1:30 I
want her to come to mine for a little
bit before hers but she's not having it
because she's got to help her mom cook
well this is easy so you just say you'll
be over there [ __ ] 1:30 and you're
just gonna make an appearance what she
gonna make you not see your family on
Thanksgiving you said on one hand I'm
super salty and want to be a huge and
want to make a huge deal about this
because I really want her there and I
think she's being selfish but on the
other hand I understand she's got to
help her mom cook and stuff at least
that's her excuse I know she loves her
family but it really pisses me off
because she's never been to my family
[ __ ] but I've got gone I've gone to
plenty of hers her defense is that she's
never made me miss any of my family
gatherings to go to hers but my family
is a bunch of nutjobs and you get the
point
old Billy burnt dick I could use some
words of wisdom I'm a huge fan thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself happy holidays huge
fan well I mean this is all your doing
so you can undo all of this all right
you know you just got to put your foot
down just say listen I respect I
understand you got to help your mother
cook but I you know I want to see my
aunt my family on Thanksgiving so I will
go over there I'll be there over the for
an hour all right and then I'll be over
here 1:30 and time to eat and if she has
a problem with that just ask her why do
you have a problem with that this is
perfect I'll you don't have you don't
have to come you don't have to come to
my family of nutjobs as you say and
yeah she's trying to get out of going to
your families is what I'm wondering
because most people I feel like in the
situation you just split it up so she's
got to go help her family cook you could
go over there with her while they're
doing that talk to the dad of the
brothers whatever I don't know if
they're gonna be cooking or whatever
spend that time have the meal and then
the two of you then go to your your
family's house for dessert and like
coffee and a movie or game night or
whatever you know but there's his starts
early it starts at 12 there starts at
1:30 so I'm saying I just I tell listen
you go over your mom's house you cook
I'm gonna old my aunts from 12:00 to
1:00 I'll be back at 1:30 you show up
like and then you show up at like 140
you don't even spend like an hour though
that's nothing because you like the food
isn't going on the table right at 12:00
everyone's gonna like saunter in around
12:30 12:45 sit down
then eat I would take it's gonna be this
this is what I would do I would say this
is deal I'm going in there for an hour
then I'm gonna go over to 1:30 right
1:30 I'll be at your place but next year
we're going to my family's this isn't
even like I'm not gonna like never see
my family on Thanksgiving again right I
would never do that to you are you
saying I can't see my family anymore on
Thanksgiving you just do that oh yeah go
to his family's and just say hey text me
when you guys are about to like sit down
because she's gonna cook and do all this
other stuff so it was like text me when
you guys are about to sit down I'll let
you know where I'm at with my dinner and
then I'll just come over there and then
what you need to do is say it totally
calmly do not trash her do not do not
and say anything insulting about her
family do not let her when you stay calm
if she does that thing where she then
tries to bait you into a fight do not
take the bait just ask her why she's
reacting that way or just just stay calm
stay on target
starwars right you just you just make
your points and that's it yeah that
sounds reasonable well there you go so
you like how great a movie was
Casablanca it was really nice I finally
understood the [ __ ] movie I always
got confused
love story but I didn't quite understand
you know unoccupied France and they're
talking and like Nazi Germany and [ __ ]
it's just like they taking over your
country and it's just like I guess they
had their their power hadn't gotten to
that point cuz it was like Italians
soldiers there there was German soldiers
and there was [ __ ] these these German
Nazi guys I don't know I'll have to
watch it again I'd maybe read a little
bit of [ __ ] history but I actually
understood the love story this time was
[ __ ] great yeah how beautiful is that
woman - huh yeah she's beautiful yeah
she was like modern day beautiful - a
lot of them back then are back then
beautiful you know I mean like hey what
do you say they're [ __ ] Ellis Island
ya know she's a classic duh ah there she
goes sleeping like a damn dog lately
because you're conditioned because of my
condition makes I'm very tired I think
you're being a jerk about it personally
maybe you're being a jerk about it I'm
not wise my [ __ ] leg hurt oh my god
I'm gonna end up like those [ __ ]
people in the orchestra pit just will
[ __ ] Lee see that one guy was like 55
just sitting there
he look like he just fell off a
motorcycle good anyways well I'm glad
you had a good time I hope you enjoyed
it because I'm watching all the rest of
the football Sundays from here on out is
I empty the liquor cabinet so is that
our last Sunday out is that what you're
saying until no I would like to do that
I've been actually and I've been looking
up museums and [ __ ] on the down-low
trying to understand Arden really
understood it I find that I like I
figure out what period it is it's the
van Gogh when the period after van Gogh
I like that [ __ ] okay that's cool I
liked it the abstract I'm starting to
understand that well you don't need
lines you have colors to suggest moods
it's like I look at you kinda looks like
five year old it's always gonna look
like a five year old didn't do you like
modern art do you think or do you like
the more old classic stuff like the van
Gogh versus the Jeff Koons
I don't know Jeff kunis Andy Warhol Andy
Warhol was the original hipster and his
brutally brutally [ __ ] overrated Oh
huh take it was not a nice person
what about Basquiat did you like
Basquiat I like Basquiat is that the
dude looks like saving Glover but he
painted Oh
oh my god haven't heard that name in a
while uh yeah seed sort of like the
weekend before he cut his hair he was
doing like an homage to Basque yeah yes
that's all I was on Michel Basquiat
that's the most modern person I listen
to yeah we can to the point i
pre-ordered his next album I know I my
god I got his I got the first two songs
you did I want to hear it we should
listen to it after this absolutely as I
like to sleep because of my condition
how far are we talking about my
condition not that much right I mean
like we're not gonna get into all like
all the specifics no we're not I'm just
something's good yeah the sex and all
that yeah what it is yeah pictures no
none of that [ __ ] okay yeah it's just
like the kitchen you're just gonna know
it got redone I share enough there's too
many [ __ ] weirdos on the [ __ ]
Internet I don't I do not understand
people that post pictures of their
children you know how'd you get excited
with your [ __ ] home address right
above your [ __ ] head for them for the
family photo cuz they're so cute you
just want to like show off you know but
I definitely understand why we will not
be doing that all right this is probably
a conversation that should have happened
off of the podcast all right you're
[ __ ] cool and what the [ __ ] did I do
to my leg I just laid down and I think I
hyper-extended my feet who is that
me yeah we always bring him up
Richard Cano Oh Robert Klein Robert
Goulet
Robert Klein I can't stop my leg very
good look at yo CI when I went saving
Glover then you hit me back whitestyle
Robert Klein all right that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
have a wonderful Thanksgiving I will be
checking in on you on Thanksgiving no
you will not yes I will no you will not
listen we're gonna eat it 1:30 I'm gonna
do a podcast to 12:00 at my parents
house you take you can take Thanksgiving
off people will understand yeah I
believe your people said money Never
Sleeps 24/7 what are some of that's
stupid [ __ ]
they sleep we grind yeah all that dumb
[ __ ] like like Bill Gates isn't doing
that you're gonna do a podcast on
Thanksgiving what is wrong with you
well maybe you'll do it the day before
Thanksgiving that's a big pet peeve of
mine when performers Oh talk about how
[ __ ] hard they work you know they
take those pictures of him where they
look they've got their head down like
they're [ __ ] exhausted you know and
then he just said Lisa these [ __ ]
self-imposed compliments you know a lot
of people would stop I feel like I'm
just beginning but that's essentially
what you're doing if you're gonna be
working on Thanksgiving no nothing no
that was a really weak way to try to
manipulate it back in me I'm gonna do it
so if you just if you want to have the
argument now cuz I'm gonna do it no I'm
too tired
there you go go to sleep seriously
you're putting on a lot of weight in oh
my god I'm not attracted to you right
now I just don't understand what it is
that's not true don't tell me that yeah
you just told me I look beautiful you do
look beautiful you still look great
you're all [ __ ] baby my belly you're
all belly so anyways all right I'm uh I
don't know I'm gonna figure out how to
make a [ __ ] pan into a griddle and
make myself something because I'm an
adult and I just I can't [ __ ] have a
griddle I'm sure you'll figure it out no
I'm getting that growth I'll get rid of
those [ __ ] tables out there there's
too many [ __ ] tables huh what do we
have in the last supper
as Jesus coming back right in our back
[ __ ] yard that long-winded do she's
gonna sit that toilet but good boy
you're a good dad are you thrashing oh
yes you thrashing Jesus no easy Jesus is
that what Kanye goes by easy hey radio
[ __ ] you I want to get I'm gonna get
that big I'm just yelling at a [ __ ]
what would you call that when is radio
form of communication yeah yeah just
yell at a form of communication and they
cancel a show at the [ __ ] magic but
you ham radio we get it Kevin Hart's
funny but so Sam oh who's that kid I saw
and [ __ ] the new Def Jam first of all
Tony rock crushing it as a host Tony
rocks a [ __ ] star by the way remember
years ago when he had a sketch show the
next big guy [ __ ] flops me he pops on
TV Robert I forget his last name you
sweet or not Tony not Tony Roberts Tony
Roberts I know the name of the comic
that you liked you tweeted about it his
name was Robert something oh yeah he was
[ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] hilarious and
didn't give a [ __ ] if the crowd liked
him he had that the [ __ ] Luther
Vandross joke oh my god
yeah I don't wanna ruin it but yeah just
definitely check that because if that's
how funny that shows is that that show
is back in a big way and it was great to
see Tony Rock getting that gig you know
definitely deserving ending on a
positive note that's right go [ __ ]
yourselves I will talk to you on
Thanksgiving and that's stopping you
here in the background will be Nia
unapprove it smoothly making stuffing
all right go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great week great short week all right
and off to Wednesday night the greatest
[ __ ] night ever
if you're a young man right you go back
to your hometown what's-his-face the
thrill ride the thrill ride did a great
rant on that who lets rail ride the 101
man [ __ ] oh yeah that guy we'd that
guy that guy should be in the WWE he's
one of the best people on the [ __ ]
mic
not about him yeah he [ __ ] said that
that's the night you go back and all the
women you know you went to high school
with that you were afraid to talk to now
you come back you got your little man
mustache you make something happen and
now before Thanksgiving like four things
make it happen that's right
okay I love Thanksgiving oh I love but
Thanksgiving if we just rub it in the
[ __ ] English England's face you know
take that right
what no there's a lot of people in this
country that think it has to do
something with our independence with
England yeah well that's one of my
favorite things to do is I say that to
[ __ ] London ears and [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
you know what I forgot to bring up
there's a I got to do another benefit
speaking of that a buddy of mine who did
stand-up when I started out and then
moved on to writing Pete come and such a
great guy unfortunately passed away Oh
Oh God a couple weeks ago was a absolute
shock he's like a [ __ ] year older
than me
was in great health and just had a heart
attack
unfortunately so we're gonna be doing a
benefit at the Laugh Factory on December
6th tickets will be going on sale soon I
should probably know by Thanksgiving but
uh he's got two beautiful twin boys too
only ten years old and the great thing
is gonna be so great was Jamie Masada
put his name up on the marquee I'll
never forget that he did that that was
such a great thing that he did that
because Pete hasn't done stand-up in a
number of years it was great that Jamie
remembered him he's a great guy Jamie
Masada he remembered him he put his name
up there and so there's a bunch of
Boston guys I haven't seen we're all
gonna be on the same [ __ ] show and
I'm trying to think like the last time
we all work together like that was
probably the [ __ ] Kowloon about 20
years ago so it's gonna be a good
reunion we're only telling great stories
about peak um and so yeah it's gonna be
December 6 and I'll get you guys that
link as soon as I get it if you're in
town you'd like to have a laugh it's a
great cause all right that's it they
have fuckos have a nice Thanksgiving